citizens of the reject Nation it is John
it is Roxy stryer and we are back to
continue our journey through the blade
films Blade 2 today starring Wesley the
Snipes how are you feeling Roxy are you
excited you know what got me stoked what
all of their comments that were puns on
blade that I asked for and they gave me
I read every single one some of them
went over your head they did one guy was
like I'm not sharp enough to come up
with a blade pun and I was like you'll
get
ah I see what you did keep those puns
coming people and also keep hitting that
like button that helps us out the most
as well as subscribing hitting the
notification Bell and keep subscribing
to Roxy and the world girls all across
the social medias they got great content
for you that you can be missing out on
right this moment unless you subscribe
and uh Hey last but not least if you
want to get the full experience of these
reactions everything that doesn't make
these highlight reels come join us over
at patreon.com the real reject sync up
with your own copy of Blade Two join us
for all the fun check out everything
else we got over there as well and
without further ado
it's time for blade too oh the rhyme
bars
it makes it better when you say bar it
always does
New 52 it's a reference
[Laughter]
that Amalgamated Universe crossover
are you okay to give blood we came up
with some unusual results from your
blood test how unusual
as unusual as you're acting your blood
has a very rare phenotype one we haven't
encountered before
here's a lot the good news bad news
scenario Jared
good news for us
bad news
whoa
for you is he a day Walker blood welcome
to Prime Time [__]
whoa dang
oh
fish
[Music]
what just came out of his mouth
forget what you think
vampires exist
my name
is blade they call me
the day woke up that's right 20 years
ago I met a man that changed that
Whistler
oh buddy rip two years ago he was
attacked
they took him
and turned him into the thing I hate
most oh they turned him we didn't know
that right they left it off like he
killed himself
hahaha
it's like Wolverine's lashes yeah or
like two steaks two fangs nice
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
what year is this
two thousand
two two that was interesting that visual
was interesting looked a little
different than the first one yeah it'll
be interesting to see how the effects
grow and the ways in which they shoot
around the effects
love that Boomerang knife
good stunt
forever
take me to it and I'll consider you a
loose ends whoa
[Music]
bloody cocaine I think it is that's
awesome actually logistically I don't
know if that would work because I'm
looking on Powder together would not be
able to maintain that consistency
maybe it's like Crystal
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh Night at the Roxbury that's right
nice
[Music]
damn you want to get nuts let's get nuts
oh
you can tell he feels really confident
in this role absolutely it's like I
crushed you last time I'm settled then
tell me to slow down my martial arts
skills old man
look at what they've done to you
whoa
whoa awakened from The Matrix I want to
know the science behind why they keep
them in that water it must be some kind
of blood
suspension yo yes of course a classic
blood suspension well let's assume
everything has blood in it
let's go poor thing
let's go home buddy your daughters boys
and girls
whoa what
is that Norman Reedus oh no way
if there's anything left of you in there
listen up
in the morning those blinds are going to
open whether you're cured or not damn is
he using like Karen's formula did she
perfect it yeah I just thought that this
far in you weren't able to
he looks like Eddie Furlong a little bit
what do you know Norman Reed is from
mainly The Walking Dead I haven't seen
Boondock Saints
are you sitting next to me I know
blasphemy one day how'd you find me
started out in Moscow in Romania they
kept moving you around how long was I
gone
too long
years okay but Exposition us for a
second how long was he
where's Mark
whoa
what are you doing in the man's engine
let's go cannabis
Josh you can call me Scott though gave
it a more aggressive exhaust profile
ramping burn the damn thing out before
your next oil change the what's your
problem Poppy
I built this operation you asked wife
yeah Daryl
whoa body temperature 50 I guess suck
head
damn the alarm sets off the
cinematography coverage too
okay ninjas
cool very cool
they are ninjas
cool outfit yeah Yep this feels like it
should be a Cirque de Soleil show oh my
God Cirque du so blade let's do it
all the Twirls
no I like they're using the boomerang
blade more though that's the one thing I
wanted more of the first one yeah what
do you think these people are I guess
they gotta be like super Vamp ninjas or
something whoa
whoa
yeah
well you could have just said so we
represent the ruling body of the Vampire
Nation they want to meet with you
[Music]
my name is Assad this is Nisa
two more beautiful people yep but now
there's something else loose on the
streets something worse than you now we
gotta work together sometimes the ADR is
a little off yeah and that's fine it's a
mark of the time yeah it is totally fine
oh oh I really don't like the way he
looks this is Overlord Eli damasquinos
big an arbor virus carried in the saliva
of predators in 72 hours its spreads
through the human bloodstream creating
new parasitic organs like cancer they
did a great job with his design yeah
creepy magic of silicone on olive oil
sure glycerin Jared nomak
Pizza not just humans but vampires as
well
you want me to hunt them what do you
think they'll turn on next we spent two
years training a small Tactical Unit the
blood pack we want you to lead them the
blood pack I had enough of their world
if you [__] and breaks because they're
no longer top of the food chain I think
you should watch them nobody goes cold
turkey from The Thirst in just one night
okay all right I was thinking that was a
little quick yo Norman Reedus is Bomb
yeah man I'm glad he's on the squad
looking to get hooked up maybe what do
you have a horse Hawaiian ice whatever
you need Hawaiian ice horse like a snow
cone I like that
what if I need you
[Music]
whoa wait what's that what's that whoa
wait what was that
I am not sure oh it's a piece of the
glass from the oh yeah
it looked like a crystal
oh
this movie is a vibe to it it's like is
the vibe yeah it's dark yeah in a good
way
squirmy light hammer verlane priest
Snowman
what Donnie Yen do you think that's why
we weren't allowed to look anything up
all right and run Perlman no please whoa
if I'm not recognizing the rest of them
I feel bad but damn I'm stoked right now
you've been training for two years to
take me out and now here I am
oh so exciting
Here I Am Ready in front of you go ahead
Adolf here gets the first shot
oh
wow now you got an explosive device
stuck to the back of your hand
Suicide Squad we're talking all the
night places where vampires congregate
blood banks safe houses bigger the
better what's first
freaking cool so cool the House of Pain
Jump Around Jump Around jump up jump up
but get down
it's good it's good I sat down with Ron
Perlman for an hour really he was
amazing oh I'm jealous could not have
been cooler I listened to that house of
pain song for an hour it's almost as
though almost as dope you won't ask for
one of us like I give a [__] no he's
right why don't you post up on the roof
over there cover our backs so the blood
packs calling the shots now huh and I
want to lose you again Whistler yeah
vibes
Vibes
oh they do look dope
wow Donny what yeah man I am excited
we're on a Donny tear you gotta be
kidding me
another Blood Rave
they all look like Eliza Dushku that was
a look back yeah a specific whoa hey
guy from earlier
he'll enjoyed that
whoa what's happening there they're
doing like Body Mods and like Kink club
stuff but like to the vampire degree
look at them after these bastards
they're not even pure Bloods why don't
we just kill everyone
what is his name he feels like another
Sons of Anarchy dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh Great's in the floor so the blood
will drip through could be for the booze
day Walker
he could smell the daywalker yeah he's
got to have a signature scent is anyone
born half human a day Walker I don't get
that scent we'll have to dive back into
the comments because people were kind of
enlightening us yeah I think what's the
man on the roof I got on the roof of my
bus
oh no is it Whistler is Whistler not
doing so good
a pretty cool sticky camera
you should get some yeah
yeah oh
um
his back really freaks me out his back
they're like yeah tiny little rows of
teeth look I have Goosebumps everywhere
right now you really do yeah it really
freaked I don't know for some reason the
style is really grosses me out yeah
I mean it is it's effective yeah
this is a dumb question do guns work in
the rain I think it can present issues
but in movies they always work in the
rain
oh no no what am I to you is the enemy
of my enemy my friend
or my friend
laughs
let's go let's go Donnie they remind me
of these villains in Buffy
whoa
more Donnie more fights more Donnie more
fights more Donny more fights
come on yes
[Music]
okay
oh my God there's so much going on it's
hard to tell where we're who's winning
come on
[Music]
I love guy liner yeah right even just
pointing Donny's so freaking cool yes
guess you won't be needing any of those
bits that was Hardcore did they split
his dick in half and it's
I think how you feeling theoretically
yes are you okay I'm having Phantom
pains but it's okay don't even worry
about don't even trip I hurt
[Applause]
whoa oh my God there's like Little Shop
of Horrors that was some feed me see
more [__]
I've never seen that on a map before
[Applause]
yeah oh and if they scratch you does it
all right
oh God they're like aliens
oh what is happening
[Music]
yes
I think the scratches are gonna do it
still not he did bite them he's flying
yeah
look closer at his neck there you're
right behind him
listen to me if you're under attack use
your UV lights use your UV lights I
can't take the light
Where Have You Been everyone's fighting
a battle you might not understand John
that's true I should not judge
[Applause]
oh
that's so gross really well done yeah
it's a badass effect
we have the same enemy we want the same
thing
oh no this is wild a big chunk of this
movie has been this like one long
extended sequence you know yeah it's
like a big fight imagine how long this
would take yeah
oh here we go
reload
ah
damn it
please like what oh what kidding me
oh
blade doesn't sweat a whole lot but I do
like those moments where he's like what
damn it
yeah it's like the little micro
movements yeah the same thing blade
he is right it is kind of interesting
premise because they do want the same
things not fully but partially yeah it's
like similar motivations but one of you
is going to take over the world
oh nice
God what a boss so the vampires want the
people that can eat the vampires suck
the vampires gone yeah and this people
who can suck the vampires want the
vampires gone they bought each other's
gone blade wants both parties gone yeah
he sided with one of them as opposed to
the other seems like well because if the
the super Vamps are gonna like take over
like there'll just be no one left if
they succeed because they'll eat the
humans though vampires they'll eat
everybody the vampires are trying to
take over the humans too though it seems
like in this world he's already starting
to change yeah god of
much so far Krishna checker
man they keep telling you about the
bullets you gotta get him some sunlight
come on man just put him out of his
[__] misery
finish him that way yeah where's get
your UV
move yes
foreign
he just disappeared where were you we
lost a man priest
I'm gonna carve his [__] name on your
chest priest would be an interesting
name to Carl when you're dressed true
it would be a great conversation starter
and it comes with some implications sure
followed it down found it just like this
I think they came through here
he was trying to crawl back in the
cupboard and caught his arm
uh you've already lost one of your own
how many more are you willing to
sacrifice seemingly overall even your
own daughter everyone there we go
even her
yes he is such a Star Wars villain yeah
or a hard Conan what's killing him
they need fresh blood every couple of
hours or they start feeding on
themselves
oh almost feel bad for him open the
mouth
come on
this is [__] I think so great insult
blade is the best guy I can't believe
it's him it's Ron Perlman it's Donnie
and like what only the tongue carries
the virus
it is injected through these barbs
wow
it's a more Powerpuff Girls I'm telling
you did Bert McCracken have some or
Craig McCracken whatever his name is
have something to do with this
oh dude these things are as different
from us guys pay attention
hardwired right
oh
brains dead
body's still trying to feed yeah what
happened to Sunrise
we aren't
huh if I can suss out the light source
maybe I can make some sort of UV flash
bang grenade or something big cried
already yeah but you didn't have
disgusted working on it then now did you
decided to take them back to my tent for
a little Threes Company action
blade shows up saves my ass and the
Powerpuff Girls was playing the whole
time quite a lesson on threesomes beware
it's a trap don't ever trust it
maybe you were right
all right
hey Brand New Bag
I like them Bobby too I like the merging
good character growth for these two what
is this [__] pheromones harvested from
the Reaper's adrenal glands
they're gonna key to it they gonna love
you
be real careful when you pop your love
all right
UVS have a 10 second delay
just remember to take cover oh you do
care
about her yeah maybe it's the love story
I was hoping for yeah maybe we'll get
some blade romance I don't think so
trying to attract them not scare them
all
yeah well some of us can't see in the
dark nipple head what am I supposed to
do
just get some of those yellows on
sunglasses oh there you go sure nipple
head yeah I've never heard that before
I'm gonna start using that I don't even
know what if somebody threw that insult
at me and be like oh what do I do now
how do I come back at that yes
come on I just want a 10 minute Donnie
and fight scene that's all I want to do
we haven't utilized him enough
oh no and he's with this guy damn it
ain't nobody here but you
and US buttercup
uh no
no
no fair
drop some sunlight on him he's not your
light Hammer anymore
but life
both
she didn't want to live without him it's
kind of beautiful
desperate move
Lisa
oh God all the bones so sinister
sinister six
right now Venom's gonna bust through any
time
six
five wow
[Music]
interesting image
come on man
try to stink me to death old man
Frick y'all gotta learn [__] like that
never ends well
where's the ball pack I don't leave it
down that count give me the rest of the
fan holes
oh yeah time to nut up or shut up you
obviously do not know
that's better I thought I got it and he
did better it's okay we can't all be as
cool as blade Roxy that's what I get
[Music]
laughs
come on and I haven't mentioned the bomb
lever is stuck ah you jerk
but it looks like the bomb was there
right well yeah you said I never stuck
so I don't know what he did to it
yes damn
foreign
oh my God
wow
wait oh
you will survive this only to tell blade
about this ring what yeah
you heard mosquitoes right mosquitoes
yes I'm glad I'm not crazy in my other
vampire shows that ring it makes you a
day Walker oh but I don't think that's
what's Happening Here you never know
seems like a blood thing yeah maybe the
gene that creates these Uber Vamps comes
from a mosquito like an ancient blood
strain preserved over centuries in
Millennia or they're using mosquitoes to
spread it Army of mosquitoes no
oh there is no lover of Love shipper
ships happy ending in this nah you could
save her dude
he looks sad like a he's giving her his
blood
I love too that he like he can bring the
pathos from behind those sunglasses oh
there's something sweet about this
moment it's kind of like the yeah it's
like a tender version in Reverse from
the first movie when she lets him feed
on her to save his life
[Music]
oh damn you guys
you've done a great job
not that great
charred up his faces busted bro
yesterday
she Dishonored family crest by feeding
off of him or just by not succeeding in
the mission
they took him all our weapons even your
sword somebody's been keeping tabs on us
from inside especially your sword bro
the reaper strain didn't evolve it was
designed from the mosquitoes
for years I've struggled
with all kind of any hereditary
weaknesses whoa embryos nomec was the
first a failure that'd be a new pure
race begotten from my own flesh did she
not know immune to Silver
and even sunlight what about garlic you
want to explain how nomeg got a hold of
this ring
family
from father to son
oh boy you got a choice to make Nissan
is it Nisa or Lisa Nisa the man
oh
kiss your ass goodbye
[Music]
oh
you're wasting your time man bomb's a
dud it's never supposed to explode
you're supposed to make you feel in
control oh no
damn you see this
ugh
they needed my help to bring him here to
control nomac the old [__] he was always
just fake I mean look at him and I was
psyched when you were bonding sad about
this what do you think about that man
two things I've been on to you
since they turned you
two
it's not a dud
oh great whoa
[Laughter]
damn feels like a waste of the one bomb
you had though
hey
but it was a good moment yeah if you had
to blow up one person it's always good
to remind us who's the smartest in the
room and it's blade we're going to
harvest your blood then bone marrow
organs everything
will find the missing key to creating
day walkers
fun
wow keep talking Honky Tonk just makes
my son to me the next world
stab him with the cuffs
our enemies saved my life twice and you
have used us
your own children
oh no who do you think God really favors
in the web so you believe in God
the spider is a fly in that moment I'm
sure he means the spider yeah but no man
he doesn't know this location
[Laughter]
yeah let's go Whistler go whistling go
whistling go go oh we're supposed to
believe he really beat him up that bad
that he could get away okay yeah just
two punches he's good boom boom done
sustained
he's probably so confused like where's
that coming from
I object to being shot like this
yeah you gotta cut that wrist feed him
[Music]
oh boy
God that is
really good grossest coolest effect
[Music]
thank you
is that like Stellan Skarsgard or
something
feel like someone familiar is under this
makeup here
felt like it was like refined or
something that would be wild it's not
but yeah
go on kid go
come on he needs blood
[Music]
he's gonna emerge from that like super
hulky yeah what are you an idiot Ron
yeah Ron
oh
[Laughter]
you haven't had a tasted the real thing
in a while too
the sound yes
That Base
[Applause]
[Music]
pimple head ain't got nothing on you
thank you
ah sounded almost like a Wilhelm scream
so cool
it's like a screaming style but with a
taser prod
like my daddy said right before he
killed my mom
want anything done right you got to do
it yourself
what a weird sure thing for us to learn
[Music]
whoa
can you blush
[Music]
[Laughter]
nice great Kell yeah destroy those
embryos too wow
[Music]
we're locked in can I suppose yes isn't
it sad that you die not by the hand of
your enemy but by that of your own
children
after I tried to have you killed
the
kill him right now yeah if it's coming
oh yeah
whoa
milk wow
Peter died in a tragic Sun bite accident
whoa Turn to Stone
like his heart
[Applause]
oh it's a great teeth shot just then of
her opening up that mouth blade it could
end right here
damn
this is gonna be a good one oh yeah
what's the fate of Nisa right now she's
on the track to turning
whoa
[Laughter]
see the way those doors bent
all right
[Music]
the people's elbow there's like a
wrestling-esque quality to some of this
yeah the drama the moves and the
wind-ups and the big moves
I could use a good back crack yeah same
back's been jacked up all week
oh yeah
[Music]
ow
God the way they're shooting these
effects yeah really great
oh through the side oh get him in the
heart yeah yeah yeah even though there's
bone around it he passed it
wow
interesting oh I kind of feel for him a
bit of a tragic figure
whoa
well done what about Nisa
and she can't be long for this world she
got bit but we know he has that cure for
regular I want to die while I'm still a
vampire
oh you were the one who didn't suck yeah
I want to see the sun your parents
aren't your fault yeah right I'd want to
see this on too I think that's how I'd
want to go yeah
first and last sunrise
[Music]
kiss kiss one more time kiss kiss
buddy oh
[Music]
motherboard number three enjoyment
hey this guy you sure that the girls are
a life
last time I checked as opposed to dead
yep
tissues of course
you know
I think I forgot about you did you
[Music]
yes perfect
yes yes
David has Square well done oh
dude
legit
it's a nice little button on the end too
Wesley Snipes a producer on Toby and
Mark dude he got a producer and an exec
producer credit
well done
[Music]
what'd you think
it was so different than the first one
really good yeah this was much more of a
straight up action movie sure like it
was like jam-packed top to bottom we are
going to show you every type of fight
every bit of action
um like you won't be able to breathe the
whole time yes I feel like if that's
what they were trying to accomplish
mission accomplished yeah like I thought
they they really nicely built off the
tone of the first movie because it still
has some of that mood but it it
definitely is like faster Pace much more
chop chop you have a lot more characters
at least like you know you have a sort
of Ensemble that blade is like saddled
with for part of it
yeah this Alpha maleness of Wesley
Snipes and Ron Perlman yeah just like
there was just so much
testosterone in this film yeah Norman
Reedus and just like the whole thing
that hurt man I liked see that's the
thing is like they lured me in really
good with him and obviously
I think nowadays you know that the
effect of that only works so much better
because we have an even greater
association with who Norman Reedus is
and we trust him inclined to like him
yeah so yeah it just it pulls one over
on you that much more effectively from
this vantage point I mean I'm sure it
still worked you know back when this
first dropped but uh but yeah I thought
he was a great addition and like they
even took time to be like oh man him and
Whistler like they're they're growing to
like each other how cool uh and then
yeah the the double cross comes around
like yeah I thought they had like a
really interesting evolution of the
vampire's interesting story you know
they gave you a good amount of things
that you know it's like we got certain
motifs from the first movie back or
certain characters like Whistler comes
back
um but yeah just the way they built on I
thought was great the only thing it
could have used more of was Donnie Yen
100 that I was so sad that he got murked
the way he did and making out you know
how I feel I you know honestly like if
they're if I
you know can he find love I feel like
you know Blade Trinity uh from the vague
things I've heard over time is maybe not
the best blade but he's played Trinity
the third one I think so yeah and uh I
don't know though there still could be
one more opportunity therein for some
passion you know some passionate Romance
yeah I don't think anybody else but me
is wanting that but I really do just
want blade to be happy this was a pretty
simple movie that sounds like a bad
thing and it's not just the story was
pretty straightforward there was just a
couple of twists and turns like okay
um she her being his daughter and him
being his son and also Norman Reedus
switching sides and other than that it
was like the theme the enemy of the
enemy is either your friend or your
enemy and in this everyone's your effing
enemy yeah yeah seriously don't trust
them that's why I was harping on this at
the beginning when it's just like he why
he would side with the vampires when
he's a vampire hunter and the vampires
still want to eat all the humans but the
vampire eating people just want to eat
all the vampires and all the humans it
just was like not I knew there was going
to be some kind of a reveal or twist
because that's not the Math's not
mathing you know like didn't none of
them want the same thing as you the
enemy of your enemy can only be your
friend if you really want the same thing
and they didn't yeah I mean I I bought
it in so far as it's like okay here's
this greater threat that we need you to
take care of but it's probably a bigger
threat than you are oh Mike mignola a
visual consulted on this
um who's that uh I I think that's a
that's like a comic book author a comic
book artist it's a name I I've I've seen
on involved with Hellboy too maybe I
don't know Comics I I feel like yeah
it's probably that makes sense
um it's so good but yeah I don't know I
I mean I bought it in terms of it being
bought it too tenuous like okay I'll
help you because technically this does
behoove the both of us but the second
the job's done I'm gonna I'm back to
hunting you guys totally yeah that's how
I took that I definitely bought it I'm
just glad that wasn't what it was
because I was sitting here thinking like
while I do buy this and it makes sense I
don't think this would end well and it
didn't so yeah it's like you know the
prospect of like oh and maybe blade and
the vampires will come to some sort of
truce or something like that's never
going to happen right totally yeah but
do you how do you feel I know it's right
after about the first versus the second
is one more up your alley
that's a really good question honestly
like this one was so Punchy and I really
loved the design work and again the way
it built off the first movie I don't
know I I mean there was certainly stuff
about this that I think was like really
tight and uh like citro or tight like
they kept it tight both both yeah yeah I
mean like there was a lot of really cool
evolution of again the effects and just
the visual world that this is like I
thought this nicely adapted some of the
kinetic visual elements of the previous
movie and obviously the really
distinctive lighting all these like Reds
and blues and things like that
um I would honestly right now I kind of
have a hard time picking which one I I
like more because they're both different
in ways I appreciate and uh
uh yeah I don't know maybe by the end of
this review I'll have a better ride I
mean there's one more your favorite as
of now this one to me was a lot grosser
like this was more what I feel like and
I I wouldn't call this a straight up
horror movie but to me it kind of was
because the whole time I was like I have
the ickiest feeling inside this is
making me like really having sorry there
was a gorilla song I have to anyway
continue
so I was what I was saying was really of
interest you if you were talking about
gorilla no of course it is wait what's
gorillas there was it was in the music
credits
gorilla love gorillas
a lot of different kinds of music it was
gorillas on my mind featuring red man
I'm really happy for you thank you I
appreciate you being here for this
momentum for sure it's not like a big
deal the grossness of the effects and
whatnot so I it feels like they just are
two completely different genres almost
to me like the first one I feel like
really was
um and I don't want to say used a lot
more calm no Reapers no real Reapers
were hurt during the making of This film
it's funny it's funny continue
oh gorilla
I'm sorry it's it's give me this year
look at all the credits it's good I I
loved I I you know I grew up in a
credits household yeah I feel you I I
totally feel you
um I think that the first one had a lot
more comic book movie tropes to it which
is not a fair even thing to say even
though I don't mean it as negative I do
mean as positive but it created those
tropes you know like this was the OG of
a lot of those things yeah especially on
on screen yeah right so I think it was
more like classic comic book movie and
the second one was more like Gore and
guts and like
um doing its own thing and felt very
confident and had its own Freedom so I
feel like first one maybe better date
night fun movie second one more like uh
you're having a a night with the homies
and you're like ah gross man yeah let's
watch something hard yeah yeah in a way
this not it's not a good one-to-one but
I think there is a some comparison you
could make between the difference
between like alien and aliens
kind of happens here with Blade versus
Blade 2 at least in like they're both
pretty like action-packed and they're
both pretty Snappy but like the first
movie certainly takes more time for
certain things and it has a little bit
more like breathing room which I wasn't
like missing yeah or anything like that
but it just yeah it feels like it was
paced and sort of disposed a bit
differently and this one yeah had like
really kind of upped that kinetic energy
and yeah like everything was like Chop
Chop not in a way that felt like yeah it
was pared down from something or slided
but yeah like much more to the point
much more action-packed and more yeah
the first one maybe reminds me more
distinctly of like a graphic novel
whereas this is more down the rabbit
hole like even more horror Vibes and
horror movies [__] and and certainly at
home obviously within the Comic Book
Realm
um but it's yeah and this one I wasn't
even really thinking about that aspect
yeah I'm with you the the effects of the
the super vampires but the next stuff oh
yeah
unreal yeah and and I gotta say like I
love the design of that and I love that
they took the time to you know somebody
Guillermo del Toro or or maybe it was in
the comics or whoever like they took the
time with these Reapers to figure out a
biology for that like I love that they
had that whole autopsy sequence because
it's like okay these things are
completely different inside and like
this whole like bone covered heart thing
and yeah opening up the jowls and seeing
this like disgusting Barbed tongue
apparatus and I mean part of that
especially that one profile shot I'm
sure is an alien tribute but but yeah I
just love the the amount of detail and
attention and care that went into
designing these disgusting creatures and
then just the effects looked great on
them and and across this movie I thought
they did a really nice job I mean like
in the earliest scenes you can tell that
like the people getting powered up you
know like those look a bit like Graphics
now and yeah you can tell when CG is
happening but I thought like they it was
a combination of they knew when to put
like the most work into you know those
hero shots where you need it to look
great because the lighting is very
bright and whatnot
um but I thought yeah they shot stuff
well to really bolster both the reaper
effects as well as the comic book movie
requisite like flipping and acrobatic
effects and I thought they did a nice
job here of blending stunts and shooting
the stunts in such a way that the
transition between like the CG body
double for some crazy Flip or whatever
or you know crashing into a wall like
those transitions looked really smooth
like this is one of those movies that to
me exemplifies it's like yeah okay so
this was 2002 which you know you're
getting better and better as time goes
on you know in Leaps and Bounds with CG
but this felt like one of those things
that that looks better to me than the
time it was made in suggests it would
because they knew how to shoot this
stuff yeah I'm very with you too about
the like I guess it would be the
allocation of their funds the things
that I really hoped would look good
looked sick the the dissolving effect
um or like the sunlight effect of the
blue and kind of goes away that was
interesting an interesting choice and I
feel like maybe that was just it still
looked good enough but I think maybe
that saved them a little money so that
they could do the throat Reaper
situation which clearly cost them a ton
because each one of those was like so
intense looking and great um and like
you at the beginning I was like okay
some of these effects and then when we
get into it I'm like wow they really
used their money on this thing yeah
exactly the choreography in this is like
the fight choreography in this you just
can't even I cannot imagine how long
that took that's crazy the the other
thing I was thinking what is it called I
have a couple friends who do this and I
always forget the name of it those
people who go into the rooms and make
the sounds oh fully fully art oh my God
the fully artists for this man every
song
all the swishes and clangs and gooey
sounds and yeah all the way now it's
like a feel like it's one of those
movies that is like a feast for the eyes
and ears in so many ways and two years
without the headphones too I was like
yeah
oh yeah yeah and you're in all these
dank and drippy and icky locations and
stuff like that that drippy bro drippy
don't moist locals bro come at me with
drippy moist drippy moisture this movie
was drippy moist you are dripping it's
drippy moist okay let's hear the
building a blade two wrap then dripping
oh no I'm not a good freestyle rap right
I would need to sit down with the pen
and Pad you know classic style okay I'ma
hold you to it I'm not afraid to rap
about blade we're back for the sequel so
we're keeping it real all right we got
Reapers to hunt
Boomerang knife gun and some sunlight
um running out of Rhymes and I'm just
thinking of motifs now I see you you
said hunt the only thing I know yeah I
was going I was like don't say the word
that will get this video demonetized
there's not much room yeah bunt bunt
there you go I'm gonna punt the ball to
you it just holds up his sword someone
runs through it nice little butt you
know what what Norman Reed is smoking
that they call him it has right they
call me the day Walker fast talker
Street stalker of the night
give you a fright before I slice and
dice
slice and dice my what you know hold
your your head off
various limbs I don't know anything that
kills Vamps right honestly that was way
better than I thought I set you up for
failure and you succeeded
You Found Love in a hopeless place just
now that's right man pump the brakes I
brought my steaks don't worry oh [__]
I
really liked going back to the movie for
a second
garlic I'll think about it I really
liked that when Ron perlman's character
had the bomb on his head and it doesn't
go off and I'm like ah how did blade not
know any and then Blade's so smart and
he's like nah I didn't know and I was
like that's our hero yeah he knows all
lured you into the Trap so I could get
back at this [__] this rat in my
organization
yeah and I mean that's like a movie
Magic Moment where you're like okay I
guess he was just messing with him but
it was such a satisfying it was a bummer
again these do feel like they're from a
slightly earlier time in the way that
they're crafted and thought out because
like I don't know I just feel like if
this I I keep being curious to know what
the new Blade's gonna turn out looking
and feeling like just because these
movies do feel
I don't I don't want to say like real
movies as if to imply that the current
movies don't feel real but there's
something there's something different
about
some watching something like this it's
like you have the dedication of Wesley
Snipes and and people in the comments
were like yeah they had to tell them to
slow down because he's like a legit ass
martial artist and he's credited too for
some of the choreography and stuff so
yeah and so you have like the
tangibility of both his performance as
an actor and his physicality as you know
Blade the freaking Warrior
um but then yeah you have I don't know
just like the way the story goes and the
attention to the details feels just I
don't know it breathes
uh more like a natural script does to me
through these two movies thus far than I
don't know I don't feel as much
maneuvering from behind the camera or as
much like expository sort of like hand
holding in these movies and uh I like
that like it I don't know there's just
something about these that feels
quintessentially of an earlier point in
time obviously they are it's a little
simple which is good like I think that's
kind of what you're trying it's not
overloaded with like and then and then
and now you know it's kind of like okay
I get this story I like these character
I understand what we're doing I'm
enjoying watching this yeah maybe that's
not what you're saying no no it's yeah
no it's like it's it is convoluted
obviously and it is heightened but it's
not like this massive thing the stakes
the situation feel big enough without
feeling like so big that you kind of
lose connection with them mistakes the
stakes it's good we'll get a garlic
thing in there well you know I was
thinking about the garlic thing you
could we could just use like licks or
pick or like you know punch them in the
sure like he's a little prick or we
could go with uh like a bulb of garlics
come in bulbs don't they oh we could we
yeah I was just rhyming with the lick
part of garlic sure but you were making
a whole different word it's part of the
um I got a corgi on your cup there yeah
I do it's my dog oh you got custom-made
coffee disposable cups yeah it's not my
dog I don't have one you know what I do
nice trick for you guys I go and I buy
the teas that I like from from Coffee
Bean and then I buy my own cups and I
make them myself I just saved more power
to you do it I think that's that's a
good hack they're literally giving you
their recipe you can get the flavor on
your own thank you so much
um anyway but yeah like that far pick
far less hey not bad thank you that
combination yeah of like the story is
straightforward enough the action mounts
in a pretty linear way and yeah you have
the situation that feels big but not too
big and you have a good amount of
physical effects physical fight elements
physical blood gags physical just
various stunts and sets and there's like
so much in camera but there's also a lot
of effects and I feel like nowadays you
fall into these traps of like the way
things are written feels a little
can often especially on this movie's
type of scale can feel sort of
economically written in a different way
and can also feel uh you know especially
now with the way movies are reshot and
and geared towards the knowledge that
we're gonna rework stuff later there's
just like a more synthetic feeling in a
lot of these things now that you hope
each movie will transcend and these two
blade experiences have felt encumbered
by none of that yeah I I completely
agree I really dug this if I'm gonna be
a little nitpicky it did feel a little
long to me okay when uh whereas the
first one didn't feel that way as much I
think it's because of the the some of
the fight sequences they're not
monotonous monotonous
it's not like the same thing over and
over again but at some point there's so
much I action I like action movies it's
not my number one genre so it was like
sometimes we'd get out of a fight
sequence go into the next fight sequence
to go into a third fight sequence to go
into the fourth fight sequence to go
into the fifth fight sequence and I at
some point I was thinking to myself like
I could use dialogue right now
or a slightly more distinct flavor that
distinctifies like a Donnie different
sure I mean no the thing is we see him
we get a sequence with him using the
sword which was cool I was thrilled by I
would have loved more of and and how do
you know what he can do yeah and having
a guy like Donnie Yen like it's funny
the Norman Reedus appearance I think has
gotten more effective with age Wars I
feel like the Donnie Yen appearance kind
of gets you know nowadays with you know
the profile that he has now and what we
have seen through stuff like Ip Man and
John Wick and all sorts of other things
uh yeah you feel like damn if we had
gotten some like full ass martial arts
or or you know like real sword player
just something that plays to his direct
strengths and and certainly like you
know uh Wesley Snipes also a martial
artist and they do utilize that stuff
but there is a you have a lot of group
fights you have a lot of like you know
uh club or sewer fights yeah a lot of
the locations felt similar and there are
because the vampire thing you know yeah
like and they're places that we've kind
of trodden in the first movie right yeah
which again this will still totally work
but just thinking of things that could
have elevated it a little bit more for
me yeah yeah there's that definitely I I
wouldn't disagree I mean like I I
thought they again brought a lot of fun
and punch and spirit to the action but
like in terms of how it was all
conceived and the fact that you do have
these different you know Ensemble
characters with you know the one guy's
got a big old hammer and the one guy's
got a sword and you know like they all
seem to have like their own different
little specialty you know I think you
could have maybe rung a bit more out of
that yeah yeah I I feel you or you feel
me we feel each other
that's right drippy moist they're pretty
moist I'm always here for you okay I'm
just gonna cover my myself in a layer of
Glycerine next time and just
[Music]
days gone bye and I mean you know it's
funny because uh I don't think there was
any Gavin or Rossdale on this soundtrack
but we are at an interesting time in the
sonics of these movies too because we're
in that very electronic industrial
hip-hop space
uh and uh I appreciate I don't know like
we were grooving like there was a lot of
moments where it's like whatever's
happening right now this is me yeah yeah
and it's interesting to to kind of
process these movies because it's like
going back
I don't know why the music made me think
of this because you know like the music
in these movies have changed needle
drops of change I feel like in a movie
like this from this point in time you
would have needle drops but that aren't
treated as such whereas now they are
much more like they're the score
elements and then we got a needle draw
you know
um and so I feel like that sensibility
has changed some and it's interesting
too because I've been sitting here going
back to the The Love Story thing in
modern movies in modern any of this
superhero horror super comic book
anything I've been sitting here thinking
and Chloe and I have talked about this
too on certain videos of like I wish
there
not like you know the requisite like uh
we need a love interest blah like I wish
these recent movies would bring back
some kind of sense of passion or a love
story that you could get invested in
because I think those things are missing
they're largely kind of passionless in a
lot of ways or if there is a love story
it's very kind of innocuous whereas here
I appreciate these for not feeling the
need to do that because I feel like at
the point in time these were made that
was a more likely thing to have had
happen so I really liked it like you
have the Karen character in the first
movie who
doesn't get forced into being the love
interest even though she easily could be
and they just let her be a character who
just is stuck in this situation might be
turning who knows and has to grow and
learn and at least hold her own amidst
all this chaos awesome and then in this
movie you have the Nisa character who is
I really thought they were saying Lisa
for so long well and and the way the the
the the main vampire guy yeah I would
say it I was like he had a very soft
kind of way of pronouncing things
um but yeah it's like I liked here that
you had this like hint at some kind of a
connection of sorts with them like
there's the idea that they they could
but it's never like a a like a huge
aspect of the story and I thought it was
just enough here it's like if they had
really wanted to tease a romance I could
have gotten on board somehow but I like
the way they left it as just like
they have some kind of connection in
that they've been on this journey
together she is easily the most
benevolent of all the vampires he's had
to work with she's like the least
treacherous and and conniving and you
know she's the most sympathetic and so I
like that they at least had a tender
moment because that suggested just that
like oh man had things gone differently
uh you know
uh help me suggest to me he's a mouse
that if things had gone differently uh
you know I don't know maybe there could
have been something you know more for
the two of them
um yeah possibly I do think that I I get
what you're saying also because in 2002
if you were a love interest that's kind
of all you were yeah so it I do think
we've gotten better at you can be a love
interest and also a human being
um and that's why modern day movies
maybe like we see it so much more sure
um but I I cannot help myself this is a
Tony Curran is his name the priest guy
well you look at what LLC has done I
can't help this is just me and people
get annoyed by this and I totally get it
I love love I love love I love love in
every like I will shoehorn love into
anything sure just because I think it is
what makes the world go around and like
as corny and cheesy as it can be it's
grounding for everybody oh when Ray
Donovan he was in seven episodes that's
definitely what I'm recognizing him from
and he played uh Van Gogh in a terrific
episode of Doctor Who that's right
that's where I know him that's right
he's been in tons of stuff though
Daredevil um interesting Sons of Anarchy
there you go I was right yeah
great his is worked on tons of stuff uh
yeah so I I think that it's like most
people aren't missing that love story I
just never ever has there been a love
story in a movie and I've been like I
wish there was no love story in this
movie I'm like bringing on the love show
me the love I mean that's fair yeah I I
I I want I I'm with you when it's you
know when the movement itself is
actually invested in doing this and and
okay the guy who was the the the like
vampire King has been in a bunch of
stuff too he was in the King Kong uh
Peter Jackson movies and wanted he's in
the dial of Destiny yeah I feel like he
plays a lot of like german-esque
characters
I do too I've heard a lot of demons
different things
uh you know that's a whole other
conversation to have but uh but yeah I
I'm with you I I wish there was more
love that these movies cared about and
that could you know touch your heart
because that's fine but it's just my
little It's My Thing sure sure that was
my thing you can't have my thing it's my
thing I'm the only one who can like love
I will I will uh give up this fight then
oh okay drippy moist that's right drippy
moist signing off
but yeah man really good Ensemble I
thought even even the people like from
the faces I was familiar with to the
faces I wasn't as familiar with I liked
everybody's presence for the most part
there are a few things yeah like you
know them being like Oh we got you alone
Whistler we're gonna you know you do we
lost one of ours now we're gonna take
one of his you know it's like That's a
classic sort of Hench move or whatever
there are tropes in the movie but I
thought for the most part it it kept
just a nice clip and uh and yeah it was
pretty conscientious about everything it
tried to do like my dad said to my mom
right before he killed her yes what if
you want to get the job done right do it
yourself or whatever
good job with Blade Two honestly this
could have gone horribly wrong and it
was really good so that's huge Ops to
Wesley Snipe too because he's just so
Wesley Snipes is like so
um like you can't look at anybody else
when he's on screen he's just just he's
a star
yeah he's just so good and I feel like
that's that's what we were talking about
last time I just can't picture somebody
else playing blade but no we're gonna
see it and I mean the combination two of
him and and Kris Kristoff uh
Christopherson is it's a hard tongue
twister yeah
it's starting to not sound real I know
like uh I don't know any any word will
do uh but yeah whoever chose to pair
them up as as blade and Whistler the
casting excellent choice and uh yeah and
I like to uh it's always fun seeing like
a something from a director's uh you
know repertoire that isn't quite at the
point where like you know this was made
at a time where I wasn't like aware of
Guillermo del Toro and so now going back
it's like cool it doesn't have like 100
of all of his stylistic earmarks that we
now associate with him but it definitely
is like an interesting beat along his
journey and certainly speaks to his love
of comics and horror and fantasy and and
yeah it's it's cool because it doesn't
scream Del Toro but I can definitely see
how there's yeah the growth of his voice
through something like this for sure for
sure I mean it's also really hard to
scream Del Toro when you're working with
like a comic book movie that's a studio
that I'm sure there's a lot of input
from a lot of people yeah absolutely on
this but a different time too like this
is this is a sequence of movies I would
be thrilled to go back and listen to
commentaries or hear about because yeah
it's like looking at the array of comic
book movies now it seems like Batman 89
certainly gets a lot of credit for you
know helping open the door to like oh we
can take this kind of seriously and
something like this I mean certainly
feels like it's unencumbered by anybody
going Comics or for kids you know so uh
yeah oh yeah that our R rating man
blazing trick yeah seriously blazing a
trail it earned that R and God that
little whole Ninja bit at the beginning
that was cool with the sound too it kind
of gets hot as it yeah there's a lot of
clever and fun choices in these movies
I'm excited to check out part three even
if we may be past the agreeable quality
of the Blade trilogy yeah I'm still
interested but I'm still here for it and
maybe we'll love it who knows and uh
speaking of things that I'd be excited
to check out I want our Ip Man reviews
to do well so we can please check out
the fourth one we gotta finish it and
then the fifth one yeah yeah because
they're gonna make it I'm excited
well you know keep on watching those
Donnie Yen videos keep on watching these
Blade videos you got any more stray
thoughts before we hit it no good job
team Hells yeah way to go could you if
you all watching Leslie I know you're
watching Wesley Snipes big fan of the
channel good job team appreciate all you
guys for sticking with us if you need a
love interest for Wesley Snipes I know
somebody
who would be very happy to sign up do
you yeah can you think of anybody
somehow some way I do know someone I
can't imagine who you could be speaking
about
but it's okay live Live Your Dream Live
Your Dream
he is I he's seeing him and Donnie in
the same movie was almost too much
I know right I I don't I do not uh yeah
I I second that sentence and I think in
some ways they spared us because if
there was more Donnie we might not be
sitting here in such good shape I think
we are right now there's one scene where
he's in the back putting his shirt on
he's not supposed to be a focus of
attention I can't tell you what they
were talking about in the scene because
I was like Donny's oh nervous perfectly
placed there and I was like point to the
scene oh Donnie
[Laughter]
will leave us new thoughts people who
did you think was the hottest person in
this movie and uh yeah let us know what
else you want to see and uh leave a like
subscribe all that good stuff last but
not least still a patron of the day
Everett pixel might Baker how you doing
buddy we were thinking of which Patron
to shout out today and I saw your bright
red profile pic and thought who would
make the baddest ass vampire Hunter at
our patreon I bet that could be you
because you got might in your name
you're a strong character but also I
mean you gotta be able to slink through
the Shadows you got to be able to you
know uh you know the the the yeah think
on your feet unlike me that's why I
wouldn't be as good at your job as you
would be because you would be fast you
would be sharp as a blade you would be
prepared yeah you would have all the
what would you I just think you're
killing it right now yeah you're welcome
the two things I think of when I think
of Everett oh please
as a name and a thing number one ever it
sounds like Everest so you are a
mountain my friends
and that's amazing number two I went to
San semi-formal with a guy named Everett
sick yeah it was dope dude well hey
things maybe you can guys can get
together and go to another semi-formal
feeling of full form I think it's
illegal for me to go to a semi-formal
anymore all right a full form we go full
form 100 formal you heard it here
Everett just get your Vamp gear meet
Roxy for uh let's go ever best ass
formal of your young you can just stop
at Best ass
sure I bet maybe it has an amazing I bet
Everett has an amazing average ever it's
got a mountain bird
he's got bubble butt yeah everybody out
here doing squats I feel like that's
more of a hill a Mountain's pointy yeah
yes you don't want go on too many Peaks
on that ass as long as there's some
valleys to follow
yes we love you thank you for sticking
around for whatever this is and uh we'll
see you next month and stay pledged we
love you and I hope you're doing well
whatever this is
thank you